ich will kein Ärger bekommen ich will
kein Kameramann ja alles gut
professionellen Kameramann hinter der
Kamera meine Damen und Herren schaffen
allerdings soll es heute nicht um den
extrem professionellen Kameramann hier
heute hinter der Kamera gehen meine
lieben Freunde sondern um eine Menge
Süßigkeiten ich mit Sandra Punkt gekauft
habe
lecker das kaputt gegangen nein
sag was auf was für ein Mensch früher
wir haben auf jeden Fall ganz viele
Schoko Süßigkeiten eingekauft und zwar
Schokobons nee das ist kein Schoko nee
das haben auf jeden Fall auch noch
geholt wir haben Happy Hippo wir haben
einen Kinderriegel wir haben Duplo wir
haben Maß wir haben Kinder bueno wir
haben eine Messi Schokolade hanuta Oreo
wix und ein Bügeleisen habe ich leider
nicht
also spart euch bitte die ganzen
Kommentare zu den Falten mit meinem
T-Shirt danke
und zusammen mit Milch pürieren um uns
dann den krankesten
Süßigkeiten Schokodrink zu mixen es gibt
also wir haben alles an Schoko
Süßigkeiten genommen Supermarkt von
daher würde ich sagen starten wir mal
mit der Grundlage und
nehme ich erst die Flüssigkeit rein oder
Nein erstmal die Schokolade pürieren
Entschuldigung
haben da drin was jemand der abgebissen
hat nee ganzes Ding rein wir packen auf
jeden Fall das allererstes das Ü-Ei hier
vorne in den Mixer das können schon geil
werden nachher aktuell bzw eigentlich ja
generell immer eine relativ kleine
Ernährung deswegen würde ich sowas nie
trinken oder essen ich würde auch
generell ich bin gar kein Schokolade
verändern
irgendwie alles was Fett ist es macht
boah das riecht schon wild ne
wahrscheinlich längste Praline der Welt
bitte entschuldigt die Kamera Haltung
so schwer
drin liegt
nein dann haben wir noch das Kinder
Happy Hippo da gab es ja auch mal welche
wo drauf stand selfie Sandy
auch ganz viele darüber geschickt sind
Kinder Happy Hippo Kakao das normale
weil eigentlich sind die früher waren
die doch anders oder dabei kein Kakao
drin boah das riecht schon so wild
lecker
aber ich hoffe mal ich hoffe der
Stabilisator da drin der hilft mir es
ist glaube ich das ungesundeste Video
was hier hochgeladen habe allerdings
haben wir dafür auch schon den passenden
Sponsor
fürs heutige Video am Start
wie ihr alle wisst liebe ich Wasser
Wasser ist das gesündeste was wir
unserem Körper hinzufügen können ich
glaube wir können wochenlang ohne Essen
überleben aber ohne Wasser nur einige
Tage aber die Sache ist allerdings das
ganz ganz viele zu wenig Wasser in ihrem
Alltag trinken unter anderem
er ab ist das weltweit erste Duft
basierte
Trinkflasche habt und etwas trinkt
entsteht durch den Sog einerseits
natürlich logischerweise dass das Wasser
in eurem Hund kommt aber auch die Luft
die durch den luftpott das ganze
zirkulieren lässt alles riechen im
Rachenraum wird nämlich die
aromatisierte Luft von unserem Gehirn
als Geschmack wahrgenommen obwohl wir
eigentlich nur Wasser trinken und da
gibt es weil er auch ganz ganz viele
verschiedene Geschmacksrichtungen wie
beispielsweise hier sich Cola Apfel
Mango Passion Maracuja aber wir haben
noch ganz viele andere Sachen also
wirklich auch crazy Geschmäcker wie
beispielsweise Basilikum Zitrone hat ich
gesehen auf der Website
gibt übrigens Geschmack für fünf Liter
die sind halt auch mehrere Duft drin
sondern Verpackung eine drei Stück die
Sache ist allerdings dass auch die
komplette Flasche BPA frei ist also du
kannst sie
oh mein Gott es riecht jetzt schon ich
rieche es bisher
[Musik]
so krank wenn man so Gerüche übertragen
könnte ne wir befüllen jetzt allerdings
unsere Flasche erstmal mit Wasser man
kann entweder Leitungswasser nehmen oder
also stilles Wasser oder halt auch mit
Kohlensäure funktioniert mit beiden
jetzt setzen wir unseren Trinkhalm und
Verschluss wieder drauf machen das ganze
Fest wenn wir unseren Duft jetzt bis zum
Anschlag drauf haben ist das Ganze quasi
deaktiviert das heißt man kann ganz
normal sein Wasser trinken ohne Luft man
kann das aber auch hochziehen dann ist
das Ganze aktiviert und wenn ich jetzt
sauge
ich ich check das nicht ne ja ist ja
auch nicht danke schön das heutige Video
unterstützt haben es ist eine richtig
geile Sache und wir machen jetzt weiter
mit dem Video wenn ihr euch allerdings
interessieren als nächstes haben wir
hier oben oder würde ich jetzt einfach
mal sagen was für drei so oredinger
damit reinpacken zerbröselt jetzt
einfach mal auch so ein bisschen die
ganze Hände
guck mal das Gesicht
von den Sachen die wir hier drin am
Wasser zu also am liebsten gegessen
immer in der ersten großen Pause
gegessen um 9:30 Uhr das war knapp was
ah ja ich will die ganze Zeit die Hände
waschen das ist so ekelhaft finde ich ja
aber dicker bei denkst du ich bin Mucki
mehr als nächstes kommen wir jetzt hier
zu den Schokobons das auch irre dass sie
alle noch mal einzelne Plastik verpackt
und da drin ne ne
Rolle
die größten Konkurrenten was so dieses
Schokoriegel Ding angeht wenn man mal
die ganze kinderfabrik da außen vorne
[Musik]
Snickers und Tricks Snickers das sind
die Namen so ja Milky Way gehört auch
noch zu und Lions Client line
Bild hey Leute
mit rein ist auch normal ja weißt du
warum weil wenn es schmilzt klemmlich
einander
Sprachen lernen Babbel nennt man sowas
auch ne
das ist so super ein kompletter
Kinderriegel kommt natürlich auch noch
mit rein mit Kinderriegel verbinde ich
immer meine Oma damals äh
väterlicherseits die haben uns immer
Kinderriegel geschenkt als Süßigkeiten
die hat nämlich was anderes wir hatten
mal die Theorie meine Schwester und ich
dass die einfach mal irgendwann viel zu
viele gekauft und die einfach loswerden
muss weil die waren auch teilweise echt
abgelaufen auf pass ich habe Messi noch
Schokoladentafel gesehen und wer ist das
jetzt machen
es ist okay Mass als Eis dieses Maß
Eisen sehr lecker geil aber so eine
Riegel hier so ein Schokoladen overload
boah das ist ja nur so Schokoladen Gelee
Masse wir haben auf jeden Fall alles an
Schokoladen Sachen die wir gekauft haben
jetzt hier drin werden jetzt noch Milch
rein füllen es sieht schon sehr sehr
sehr krass aus ne ja und jetzt das ganze
pürieren ich hoffe der Mix
macht durch
oh mein Gott weißt du wie es riecht
es riecht wie so Lion Serials
in letzter Zeit so viele ekelhafte
Sachen ne
ich finde es schon okay
zum Frühstück Vollkornbrot mit
Thunfischcreme und Salat gegessen so ein
Scheiß weißt du ich trinke ja auch nur
Wasser ich finde das gerade echt lecker
ganz schlechter schokoladendrink aber
ich finde sowieso alles was püriertes
bisschen komisch
wir wurden nämlich mal die Mandeln
rausgenommen und dann wurde mein Fleisch
püriert und dann musste ich das püriert
Essen deswegen bin ich davon so ein
bisschen abgekickt
[Musik]
wenn mich das Essen kann bei meinem Mann
rausgenommen worden sind die wurden
Schnitzel püriert was willst du den
Drink geben
ich würde dem ganzen glaube ich eine
sechs von zehn geben ich könnte das
jetzt nicht jeden Tag essen aber
trinken so ein ekliger lasst einen
Daumen hoch und dann wieder da wenn es
euch gefallen hat abonniert meinen Kanal
und klickt auf die Glocke um weitere
Videos nicht zu verpassen Sandra die
letzten drei Worte ich sage ciao
muss noch weiter runter
so ja